F: Et là on peut filmer?
G: Noooon
F: Et là?
J: Et là?
J: Lala lala la
F: Je crois qu'on soûle Gary
Et là?
Salut, aujourd'hui je suis à la Valette du Var, à l'occasion d'un festival de magie, où je suis programmé et c'est à côté de Toulon, La Valette du Var
Et il y a un Monsieur qui est venu me chercher à la gare c'est Jérôme Leleu
J: Bonjour !
F: Il a une voix de politicien
J: *rire*
F: [prenant une voix grave] On dirait Raymond Barre
*rires*
F: Jérôme Leleu c'est quelqu'un que j'ai rencontré il y a quelques années...
parce que tu t'occupes de Fantaisie Prod
J: Oui c'est ça
Une boite de prod qui monte un festival à Toulon, quoi qui montait du moins.
J: Ouais
F: Qui s'appelait Les Toulonnaises
F: Et il m'a programmé
J: Les fantaisies Toulonnaises
F: Les fantaisies toulonnaises
J: Les fantaisies toulonnaises
F: Tout à fait
F: Et il m'a programmé à l'époque où je commençais  juste le spectacle et tu as pris le risque de me programmer
J: Ouais quel risque
F: Tu as perdu beaucoup d'argent *rires*
J: Justement, c'est pour ça on a arrêté
F: Et je m’étais bien éclater, tu m'as fait revenir l'année d'après dans un... Au casino...
J: Je suis maso
F: Ben oui, au Casino d'Hyère
Comme tu sais je fais une vidéo par jour Jérôme.
J: Par jour?
F: Par jour
J: Et faut que je revienne tous les jours ou pas?
F: Tous les jours, est ce que tu as regardé les 66 vidéos qu'il y a déjà?
J: Vraiment?
F: Oui
J: Non
F: Tu m'étonnes je pense que même ma mère ne les a pas regardé
J: Personne
F: Personne ne regardera les 66 vidéos
F: *voix déprimée* Mouais
Voilà, et bien j'espère que ça t'a plu
J: *rires*
F: Rendez vous demain à 17h ^^
F: J'ai pas encore joué, en fait, je joue ce soir. J'ai pas dormi dans le train parce que j'ai monté les vidéos d'hier, en fait, dans le train
Mais hier, pour moi c'est aujourd'hui
Je bug un peu parce que je réfléchi à ce qu'on va faire
Et je sais
J: Alors moi par contre je ne sais pas du tout
F: Même toi tu sais pas du tout
J: Non
F: J'aimerai que tu penses à une ville, dans ta tête
N'importe quelle ville du monde
Une ville pour lequel tu as un intérêt ou une grosse ville ou un petit village
Tu vois, peu importe, tu en choisi une dans ta tête.
Est ce que je peux prendre ton téléphone?
J: Tiens
F: Tu l'as déverrouillé ou pas.
J: Oui
F: Vas y vas y déverrouille le
C'est bon? ok
J: En plus, je suis tombé une fois sur pleins photos de toi dans mon téléphone
F: C'est vrai?
J: Oui
F: je fais tellement ça à tout le monde
F: Tu n'as pas...
Safari?
J: Non.
Si peut être je sais pas
Alors attends
*rires*
J: Alors
F: Ah si, il est là
F: Dans productivité, il a rangé Safari dans productivité  s'il vous plait
Oulala tu captes...
Ah c'est un téléphone au gaz
F: C'est ça
J: Pourquoi?
F: C'est très très rare
Ça rame mais laisse tomber
Je vais me mettre comme ça que vous me voyez faire
Je vais me mettre sur Maps
Point
google
point
com
comme ça on est sur google maps, ça va nous servir tout à l'heure
Tu as une ville ou un village en tête maintenant c'est bon?
J: Oui
F: Ok, là je te pose des questions tu me réponds par oui ou non dans ta tête
J: Ok
F: Est ce que c'est une grande ville?
J: Oui
F: *rires* c'est bien ça peut être la 1ère info
ok
Tu me réponds par oui ou par non DANS ta tête, dans ta tête à toi, ça doit pas passer par la bouche
J: Ok
F: Est ce que cette ville est en France?
C'est dur de pas répondre mais c'est normal
Est ce que cette ville je la connais?
Est ce que d'après toi... ah ça cherche par là c'est intéressant
Est ce que d'après toi c'est une ville où je suis allé?
F: Oui peut être
J: Je sais pas
F: Mais me réponds pas
J: Ah pardon
F: dans ta tête
euh... est ce que c'est une ville où j'aurai pu passé en tournée? est ce que potentiellement t'identifie des zones où j'aurai pu jouer?
D'accord
Le mec il veut être sympa, il *mime de Jérôme*
Ok, je vais juste prendre ton poignée
ça s'appelle du cumberlandisme
et je vais essayer de prendre ton pouls et surtout tes réactions micro-musculaires en même temps
*petit rire* ça va toi la santé en ce moment?
J'arrive pas à trouver le pouls
C'est bon
ok
Tu penses à la 1ère lettre de cette ville
et tu cherches pas à me donner d'indice
penses y vraiment
A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P, Q, R, S, T, U, V, W, Y, Z
d'accord
Penses au nombre de syllabes
Je te laisse compter dans ta tête d'abord le nombre de syllabe
Ok, c'était rapide
donc ça peut être
1 syllabe
2 syllabes
3 syllabes
4 syllabes
D'accord
ok
Je tente un coup
je tente un coup et ma foi on verra
hop
C'est tellement long
ok
J'ai pointé sur une ville
sur le google map
que j'avais fait voir
Je vais le redire c'est mieux
J'ai pointé sur une ville, sur le google map que je vous avais fait voir.
Je le fais voir à personne
Je le pose ici
On voit pas trop à la caméra je vais peut être le reculer
voilà
là on est dans le champs
C'est là où la pression monte.
Alors que c'est débile parce que si ça marche pas, j'ai juste à pas publier la vidéo
mais j'ai pas envie de te décevoir
J: Ou tu devras refaire au montage
F: Ou faire un montage c'est vrai. Mais je veux pas faire ça
F: Euh...
J: Surtout que j'ai été exceptionnel sur la vidéo
F: T'étais magnifique
A chaque fois que je me redresse, il se redresse
Par rapport à ce que je connais de toi, par rapport à la 1ère lettre,
que je pense avoir identifier,
le nombre de syllabe, que je pense avoir identifier
et toutes les infos que tu m'as donné volontairement ou pas avant
je pense que j'ai bon
Est ce que tu peux nous dire et leur dire maintenant et me dire surtout quelle ville tu avais choisi dans ta tête
J: Rio de Janeiro
F: Rio de Janeiro
Prend le téléphone
Retourne le délicatement
et fait voir le téléphone sur quelle ville j'avais fait pointer le google map
Je fais bien voir devant
Sur Rio de Janeiro
F: Et il a jamais réussi à compter les syllabes dans sa tête
*rires*
J: Monsieur Olicard est incroyable
peut être que je te reprogrammerais en fait
*rires*
F: En fait, je marque des points comme ça, je ne fais que des programmateurs
C'est la 1ère fois qu'un directeur de festival,  programmateur etc...
en fait, Jérôme est super cool parce que sur cette date là, comme c'est dans son secteur, c'est à Toulon.
Il m'a accompagné, il m'a drivé, il m'a fait visiter un super resto
Aller sur Facebook et rajouter Fantaisie Prod
ou il y a le site internet aussi
F: www.fantaisieprod
J: fantaisie-prod.com
F: Ouais rajouter plutôt sur Facebook
En ce moment, vous... faites tourner aussi la fille de Francis Cabrel
J: Oui Aurélie Cabrel
F: Aurélie Cabrel, il m'a fait voir les vidéos, c'est... c'est bluffant en fait
je ne m'attendais pas à ça. Elle a un vrai univers vraiment à elle, personnel
et c'est hyper intéressant
Abonnez vous à la chaîne
Je compte sur vous pour vous abonner et partager cette vidéo
et vous venez me voir aux hallucinations collectives et partout en France
Merci beaucoup
J: Merci à toi
F: Merci mon Jérôme
et rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao!